5 mai 1992 une tribune s'effondre lors
d'un match de football à furiani en
corse bilan 19 morts et plus de 2300
blessés depuis près de 20 ans les
victimes ne cesse de se battre pour
sacraliser la date du 5 mai de pouvoir
envisager qu'on puisse faire encore la
fête autour du football à 5 mais c'est
quelque chose pour moi et pour de
nombreuses personnes qui est
complètement inconcevable l'une des
premières victimes à en faire la demande
s'est lui paul cas là si c'était en 2001
neuf ans après le drame cette année là
la finale de la coupe de la ligue est
programmée le 5 mai il n'accepte à bhl
pour cet homme devenu paraplégique après
la catastrophe se faire offense aux 18
morts de froid que de programmer ce
match 2 1 ça mais ça n'est qu'une
journée de deuil pour la corse entière
malgré cette colère des matchs
continuent à être jouée à cette date du
5 mai la ligue de football ne veut rien
entendre les gouvernements n'ont plus
alors les victimes et leurs familles
continuent le combat comme ici en 2012
nous ce qu'on demande c'est qu'il n'y
ait plus de match le 5 mai et qu'on ne
dise pas que c'est pour le devoir de
mémoire pour médiatiser tout ça parce
que si on veut médiatisée on peut très
bien médiatisée les journées qui se joue
avant ou après cinq maires trois ans
plus tard en 2015
première avancée la catastrophe de
furiani est reconnu comme un drame
national par l'état en clair il n'y aura
plus de matches les 5-10 5 mai mais si
le 5 mai tombe un autre jour de la
semaine le match pourrait être disputée
aujourd'hui il y avait toujours pas de
consensus sur une sur ce gel total donc
sur la façon de rendre hommage donc on a
trouvé qu'à travers ce ce compromis qui
satisfait tout le monde c'était le
meilleur moyen de satisfaire leurs sont
des parkings insuffisant estiment les
familles des victimes le combat continue
2010neuf des matches sont programmés un
dimanche 5 mai la ministre des sports
roxana maracineanu est interviewé sur un
gel des matches ce jour là
silence gêné de sa part est-ce qu'il
faut supprimer tout match de football
professionnel ce jour là le 5 mai à
cette date là
je n'ai pas forcément d'avis sur la
question en réponse les familles des
victimes crient leur colère aujourd'hui
la ministre des sports elle elle n'a pas
elle n'a pas d'avis sur 19 morts et plus
de 2000 blessés c'est juste honteux mais
le combat fini par payer un an plus tard
en 2020 le 13 février en première
lecture l'assemblée nationale vote en
faveur d'une proposition de loi pour
qu'aucun match ne soit joué 1,5 mais peu
importe le jour rien n'a été facile au
bout d'un an contraire aujourd'hui mais
on a réussi à être entendu donc c'est un
véritable soulagement et une grande
satisfaction ce jeudi 29 ans après le
drame de furiani la proposition de loi
doit être examiné par le sénat avant
peut-être d'être définitivement adoptée
en seconde lecture par l'assemblée
nationale
[Musique]